welcome to this channel now so something
really tragic and wonderful happened
over on MAME town's Channel you have
planned out an entire challenge based
around st. Patrick's Day for both her
and Hannah and I to participate in but a
natural disaster occurred oh my god oh
my god and we couldn't actually finish
the challenge so I wanted to use it for
my video so please no further ado
welcome the makers and takers of the
tragedy mamrie Hart and Hannah Hart
Remiel of amery explain what her
challenge was so that we can actually
play it here today you are being so
efficient direct your with this
introduction a naive Harvey of YouTube
baby I mean I did just interview Larry
King
all right so I created a challenge
that's all about luck not really I just
wanted to use the name and the looking
idiot so this is the I'm a [ __ ] idiot
challenge any four rounds just like a
four-leaf clover which signifies luck
very good and also true around one ding
do you guys know what lyrics are mm-hmm
refresh it's a good why is it old
contact lens it one man from Nantucket
whose dick was too long against theirs
how did you both have a stroke just now
it's a rhyming story but here's the
rhyming scheme a a DBA so first second
line rhyme third fourth line rhyme fit
line rings with 1 & 2
oh yeah with the sheet of paper and no
time on the clock I want you guys to
each write a limerick about me okay
great I'm gonna need some chapstick
because I just kissed your ass so much
this okay great Hannah and mamrie just
cut my hair it caused us all quite a
scare
she said oh my god the name of Allah and
no other challenge could compare
maemura gots a dog named beans her butt
looks great in her jeans she loves a
delicious dinner she's definitely a
sinner she's absolutely the woman of
your dreams
oh no lies detected basically her
Wikipedia page
despite the consequences that happened
I'm giving the point to grace Oh second
round the second leaf of the four-leaf
clover now what you guys might not know
is that there's so much I don't know
this could take a while is that last
night Hannah someone broke into your
house and they decided to partake in a
brewski luckily I showed up and scared
them away it was a leprechaun dad I
scared them off so quickly that they
left the beer here somewhere in this
kitchen is that leprechauns tiny beer so
I'm going to count down from three and
the first one to find that tiny beer
gets a point
ready three two one no no is in the
freezer like all beer the Leprechaun
wanted to keep the beer cold the thirdly
for the four-leaf clover
quoting the third leaf of the four-leaf
clover it's a round called I must ask
you a question as you can see I got
traditional Irish fake mustaches for
this one here's how this works
I'm going to ask you a question you can
throw out as many answers as you want
and the first one to just get it right
wins okay what food am I craving right
now a dull just chickpeas marsala
chicken sauce are vegan Brussels sprouts
chips totally fried chips beer I dip
hummus hummus almost twice guys do want
you to something throw it now - hi Pat
hi I drew wishes dick know when I won't
forget any potatoes lasagna not
mushroomed anything but avocados beets
roasted beets I'm gonna be honest it was
lasagna but I was trying to get him to
say something so I could give her a
point so she was still in this game
I think me ah damn it no keep it going
just say I don't know apples oh um a
jock yes good
it hard still in the game oh no I don't
know this is not my day
okay the fourth round sorry guys
all falling apart right oh yeah me too
the fourth leaf of this four-leaf clover
it's all about snakes because unless I
am remembering this Wikipedia page wrong
Ireland has no more snakes right they
drop the snakes out so that's why okay
oh my gosh I got these oversized died
and the first person to roll Snake Eyes
wins the point there's a lot of hours
you got it just kidding these girls suck
at that so now we've changed the rules
and this is a one-eyed snake if you know
what I make not a day whoever gets one
first three oh yeah i won
well guys thanks for watching the
challenge to make sure if you want to
see the tragedy that caused this video
not to be on memories Channel please go
check out name town also we told you
about the holidays favorite drinking
games over on Hannah's channel so go
check it out
I don't know I'm the only one with a
drinking frame of my friends
trachmann they dispersed like ants I was
going to say every one year one graceful
ass gonna be like congrat your prize is
a free haircut